le monde entier se préparent à fêter ses
50 ans 45 de carrière voici l'idole des
tout-petits et des moins grands
j'accueille michael jackson
à
oh
c'est toi michael anti michael tu as
fait bon voyage
je n'en ai pas envie d'autant qu'elle
savait toujours en plus on prend pas le
temps passer ces gens là tu faisais quoi
quand je t'ai déporté dans cette
émission
oh je jouais avec le club vtt dit
bonjour pierre tu as été les bons jours
ils veulent triste qui sans manche à 15
ans non j'en parle dans son histoire
lise zarifi calage maintenant 60 et 65
cents c'est toi mon petit michael quel
effet ça te fait d'avoir 50 ans tu sais
je sens quand on aime encore avec
enfants continuent toujours dit tu as
une tournée en vue côté 200 sponsorisé
par qui
94 c'est plus que du rail pour toi ça
s'est terminé comment l'histoire début
du procès là il a 25 ans il est marié à
la petite enfance mon petit mathieu il
est adorable et je suis 100 par un ouï
dire que tu es le parrain d'un mec t'as
de l'enfant d'un mec qui t'a fait un
procès pour pédophilie c'est ça le
penser si des pistes mais ça n'a jamais
empêché les sentiments n'ont écouté ça
suffit qu'est ce qu'il ya j essaie de me
toucher seul homme invisible n'allait
pas s'en passer
visible je peux dire que je les sens et
main voilà en fait quelque chose si bons
essais même si je pense que je vais
recommander bah ouais c'est incroyable
n'a pas changé et encore plus blanc mais
ouais ça le prêtre
michael mais il s'est quand même à 100
si j'étais noir avant lui c'est vrai moi
tu fais pour pas dire c'est très simple
je t'explique deux opérations par an
en 94 savait dès le 10 opérations dont 7
d'une même on m a toujours ennuyé il ya
même un moment j'ai voulu me le faire
enlever même et d'hommes d'affaires
mêlant des conseillers pas un peu
dangereux aux postulants ce qui est plus
délicate l'élongation des eaux cité
faire allonger les eaux et est vrai que
c'est tout simple et mon soutien et mon
intégré et d'armatures akitani vivier
pour gagner ces femmes à 8 cm après
l'extension l'on me demande c'est un fin
de l'opération
la prochain pour avoir enfin les yeux
violet ce sera un cadeau de noël et côté
coeur à aucune opération de
refinancement comme je dirais toujours
célibataire pas du tout non je vis avec
doctrine en crise ça se passe bien mais
aucun problème c'est juste les autres
les autres c'est notre bonheur
les rend jaloux tu sais que tu sais pas
si j'en étais encore inventé ils ont
raconté dans la presse qui n'avait joué
accroche toi au papa et à la maman avec
de belles grimaces ainsi l'offre un
procès 1
c'est à dire qu'un exemple des photos
quelle est ta star préférée michael
quand j'étais petit c'est quelques
chansons claude françois france est un
tu aimerais le voir là matin chacun je
fasse entrer par la grande porte du
temps coco
tu sais vraiment tu la rencontre et déjà
les rencontrer il y a trente ans il y a
trente ans personne ne me croyait parce
que moi j'avais dit que michael du
vêtement une star internationale
une star tuvalu chanter quelque chose
parce qu'à l'air de vraiment beaucoup
aimé
ah oui pour lui oui sans problème
[Musique]
ac
et pas sur le jeu
si dans ta vie
je suis lent départ
avec soin
ces prix d'un petit jeu
[Musique]
je pars
toi tu veux
les
charme
mais
m
tous les matins
avec ça
ça
ah ah
m
montée croissante et d'éveil jeux
dématérialisés pourquoi
mais
des matériels est évidemment oui oui et
bien michael jackson à porte un message
d'espoir aux victimes du racisme de la
pauvreté
si vous êtes en butte au racisme fait
comme michael devenez blanc tu souffres
et la pauvreté fait comme lui devenait
milliardaire le jour où tout le monde
sur terre sera très riche et très blanc
s'en sera fini du racisme et de la
pauvreté et nous serons tous frères et
ce sera merveilleux
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus